by 13 after 1/4 managed answer short
rebound batted out of bounds through DJ
had that season-high 22 against the
Lakers underneath the 4-day block by Ron
zone he gave Alonso a fake Lonzo didn't
even think about fighting on it and then
came in with the clean block what's the
timeline surveys the floor with a
shutter step with the dribble have runs
into the double-team Collison involved
[Applause]
the Lakers again stopped a fast-break a
great angle but he makes a great play on
it as he gets to swat off the glass and
then Chandler's in front on a file with
given up with two with one answer good
play by so he just stuffs dragon she was
trying to beat the clock you see they're
gonna run him off the line here is the
balance there look at that quick turn
clockwise Oh out of bounds again shot
clock is off anyway and they leave the
Lakers in scoring stole away actually
[Applause]
lay up let me this deficit could be even
bigger than what it is the son has not
surrendered the easy fast break points
and just as I say that Lounge alcohol of
easy steal eight assists and six
rebounds well look at this and the stop
talking
pick it up here Lowry will walk it
across the ring got away from one so
there was zero game but better Lacroix
was gonna pick it up
and whosever gets the bouncing kuzmic
because it goes all these starters for
the Lakers the double vision right back
to see octopus good read pylons a very
good read and Zoe who scores it still a
five-point Laker lead and one do down
the middle to pitch out to Augustin
which spin move into traffic
shot clock down to seven Mucha [ __ ] and
it taken away by ball three on three
James trailing the play
terrific defense report low they did
give up a hundred thirty points in their
13-point lawsuit or later last night the
breakout Nance has ball on closet
flubber defender nearly pucks it away he
does caldwell-pope finds James for the
easy dunk position to have the lead all
of a sudden intended him on the
offensive end give the Lakers credit
elevated their defense high percentage
offense off Turtles big-time finish by
James
for a couple of years Barnes works
himself in load they're going to take it
away for DJ reaching Gabba loves a ball
with some speed runs all the way he's
gonna finish on the break as played by
lawns over he gets the ball on the
mishandle by the Andre Jordan it takes
it the length of the floor with his left
as this is not last night where they
held the opponents of 37% right now as
they turn it over again that's it's a
guy thing
nutmeg my better days Santo that's
Chandler trying to make the play in long
zone right there as you mentioned to
make the steal and get the assist to
attack the paint a little bit more
[Music]
[Applause]
you some cut that lead of 15 down to 9
if they can turn them over and run
they're all right a judge Barnes with
LeBron on his hip logs all got a hand on
it
and lonzo's gonna get it at the other
end of it but that mystery ball is off
target Lanza it's his head there's that
anticipation I talked about with him and
a good feed to Coons both defense to
offense lobs all had five steals
turnovers for the Lakers another look at
that play by lawns Oh is he anticipated
DeAndre throwing it back to Booker and
just shot to get Paul returns the
favorite James cherry-picking nice jump
hook by Mikey but it's spud out
rebounded by capela his pass picked off
by Paul and off the steal wait at home
with suspensions handed out Paul sat for
two games and it seemed like it inspired
one team and the Lakers that kind of
come out with that fight so to speak
every game now capela